wir fangen an genau so ist es
heute beginnt der aufbruch der afd mit
diesen bereits gewählten vorstand mit
den beiden vorsitzenden mit den beiden
stellvertretenden vorsitz nicht möchte
mich recht herzlich bei den delegierten
bedanken die uns das vertrauen gegeben
haben ich freue mich ganz besonders dass
ich mit alice weibel weiterhin
vertrauensvoll jetzt in der sprecher
position zusammenarbeiten kann es hat
mir wirklich ein großes glücksgefühl auf
mein herz gebracht und ich freue mich
natürlich auch mit den drei
stellvertretern mit denen ja bereits
schon im bundestag zusammen arbeite hier
vertrauensvoll zusammenarbeiten das ist
unser ziel dass wir heute die
vergangenheit hinter uns lassen den
streit hinter uns lassen und geschlossen
die weiteren aufgaben für deutschland
für unser volk vorantreiben werden
ja auch von meiner seite gibt es
eigentlich den gesamten worten des
bundes sprechers tino copala überhaupt
nichts hinzuzufügen
ich bedanke mich für die konzentrierte
arbeit der delegierten hier und
wünsche uns allen eine sehr sehr gute
zusammenarbeit jetzt schon mit dem
gewählten rumpf vorstand und morgen
stehen noch viele anträge auch auf der
tagesordnung die wir auch konzentriert
abarbeiten werden
ja gut peter böhringer ich bin ja auch
nicht unbekannte diesem kreis und
genauso verhält es sich mit dem
gesamtgremium des bisherigen bisher
gewählten bundesvorstand ich bin sicher
es wird harmonisch vorangehen es muss
auch modisch vorangehen trotzdem werden
wir uns natürlich über inhaltliche dinge
auch einmal kontrovers auseinandersetzen
aber ich denke es wird ein bisschen
konstruktiver als bisher und im
interesse deutschlands machen wir das
was sollte vielleicht als neulinge zu
diesem gremium nicht gleich die
inhaltlichen ansagen machen deshalb
gehen wir das wort weiter
da könnte ich bin sehr stolz diesem team
dieser mannschaft bei zu gehören ich
denke es wird ein neuer aufdruck für die
afg werden wir arbeiten schon seit
vielen jahren kollegial zusammen
vertrauensvoll zusammen und wir sind
eine neue chance für deutschland vielen
dank
fünf gute wahlen bisher neun folgen ich
hoffe die werden eben nicht erfolgreich
ausgehen erfolgreich für die partei dass
die partei sich endlich darauf
konzentriert was sie tun sollte nämlich
programmatik eine außen tragen und sich
nicht mit internen sachen beschäftigen
aber ich hoffe mir guten mutes dass das
jetzt der vergangenheit zunächst mal für
einige zeit angehören
wissen sie ich habe gewonnen das ist
erstmal die hauptaussage die hier
getroffen wurde von den delegierten
dafür bedanke ich mich und natürlich ist
immer die personen die ganz vorne steht
die an der man sich am meisten
abarbeitet haben auch die delegierten
getan ich nehme natürlich auch das mit
demut zur kenntnis und ich werde die
nächsten zwei jahre genau daran arbeiten
dass es weitere und bessere ergebnis
auch mit mir an der spitze gibt
nichtsdestotrotz möchte ich mich
trotzdem nochmal dieses vertrauen
bedanken und wie dieser wie schon
eingangs gesagt hat heute beginnt der
aufbruch ich schaue nicht mehr zurück
was gewesen ist was war die ära leuten
ist mit dem heutigen tag beendet
also die ersten sachen die zu dem
aufbruch gehören ist sind das team was
wir uns auch zusammen ausgesucht und was
wir auch zusammen bevor gestellt haben
was bislang auch von den delegierten mit
großer mehrheit gewählt worden ist also
das gibt uns doch den rückhalt den wir
brauchen und die weiteren sache anträge
die werden wir wie frau weiter schon
sagte morgen bearbeiten und ich denke
auch dort wenden uns die delegierten
folgen
also ich war vorher schon
fraktionsvorsitzender ich war vorher
schon parteivorsitz nahe ich habe die
letzten monate gut hinbekommen ich bin
ein fleißiger arbeiter wie sie wissen
von früh bis spät also ich freue mich
auf die zukünftige arbeit ich bin gesund
und fit meine partnerin ist es ebenso
also von daher freuen wir uns dass und
wir werden es auch schaffen
wenn wir angetreten sind war das der
plan
[Gelächter]
das zahlen
natürlich vorstellen ja das habe ich ja
in meiner rede auch ausgeführt im
übrigen auch die anderen redner dass wir
genau diese kommunikation die natürlich
auch durch die korona krise in
deutschland stattgefunden hat das im
prinzip die kommunikation nicht
stattfand dass wir uns kaum austauschen
konnten dass wir uns nicht treffen
konnten und das wird auch zwischen ost
und west gleich wohl auch zwischen nord
und süd die nächsten monate und jahre
die aufgabe sein die wir natürlich über
bewältigen müssen dass wir dort in der
kommunikation besser wären auch intern
und trotzdem lassen wir uns diese
spaltung nicht einreden nicht von der
presse einreden diese unterschiede gibt
es in allen parteien übrigen auch in der
cdu auch in der spd diese regionalen
unterschiede muss man auch ein stück
weit an erkennen ohne sofort mit dem
finger auf den anderen zu zeigen
wissen sie ich bin vor zwei jahren mit
54 prozent gewählt worden der aktuelle
cdu-vorsitzende brauchte drei wahlgänge
um überhaupt mal vorsitzender zu werden
also von daher sehe ich das jetzt nicht
so kritisch an wie gesagt ist eine
aufgabe und an der welt messen lassen
und ich möchte natürlich auch das
ergebnis in zwei jahren verbessern
wir wollten es ist endgültig vorbei
ihre termine sind das problem
also geben sie mir bitte ein ton wo ich
nicht gemäßigt war fortan haben wir die
partei der mitte die repräsentieren wir
wie wir hier stehen und wir präsentieren
wir hier in unserer führung
der umgang mit uns selber der umgang mit
deutschland das ist unsere aufgabe ich
habe es in meiner rede gesagt wir
vertreten die interessen der bürger der
wähler wir vertreten die interessen
deutschlands wir vertreten nicht die
interessen russlands genauso wenig wie
amerikas genauso wenig wie brüssel wir
wollen für unsere bürger vereinen für
die aufgaben die jetzt anstehen politik
betreiben
[Musik]
es gibt in jeder partei diese
unterschiedlichen haltungen und auch die
unterschiedlichen positionen wir haben
ein positionspapier verabschiedet was
mit über 90 prozent bestätigt wurde ich
habe es heute auf meiner rede gesagt
auch die landesvorsitzenden außer ein
landesverband hat den vollumfänglich
zugestimmt also von daher gibt es diese
spaltung die sie ja bei reden wollen
auch zu dieser positionierung nicht
die erste projekt ist die konstituierung
das gehört dazu dann haben wir ein
geschäftsverteilungsplan wir schauen wir
uns in ruhe an und werden beraten werde
ich aufgaben auch in den zukünftigen
bundesvorstand übernimmt und ich gehe
davon aus dass sie am montag oder
dienstag stattfinden wird
wie fasst die stimmung bessert sich die
schützen
na ja also ich bin ja schon sieben jahre
im bundesvorstand
dementsprechend dann kann ich auch
vergleiche anstellen ist heute meine
vierte bundesvorstands wahl
das ist der letzte bundesvorstand ist
mit abstand der unerfahrenste gewesen
der unpolitische
und also schlechter konnte man das alles
gar nicht mehr machen das muss ich hier
auch in aller deutlichkeit sagen
der bundesvorstand war völlig anders
aufgestellt als beispielsweise der
fraktionsvorstand der bundestagsfraktion
noch komplett anders geführt wird und
wir werden das und das ist jetzt auch
eben der ganz große vorteil der
doppelspitze in der fraktion als auch in
der bundes partei werden wir natürlich
dieses erfolgsmodell auf die partei
spiegeln mit einem hervorragenden themen
wir wählen mir gerade durch mit
kompetenten leuten die haben wir uns ja
auch vorher nachdem gerade der fähigkeit
ausgesucht jeder hat seine aufgabe laut
geschäftsverteilungsplan
und was wir tun werden ist als
allererstes die strategie der partei
umstellen
und das ist das sehe ich als unsere
vorrangige aufgabe wie positionieren wir
uns dazu habe ich ja auch schon zweimal
gesprochen auf diesem bundesparteitag
und da sind wir uns auch eigentlich tino
kuba und ich dass das unsere unsere
größte prozession ist und ich bin da
sehr zuversichtlich dass das mit diesem
team was auch sehr erfahren ist
berufserfahrenen ist vor allen dingen
dass das dann auch gelingen wird
das kann man jetzt noch gar nicht sagen
wissen sie
sie können ja selbst auf diesem
parteitag nicht sagen wer wo gewählt
wird wir haben ja eine echte
konkurrenzsituation auch wettbewerb hier
und das ist noch so weit weg sie wissen
doch eine woche kann in dieser partei
sehr lang sein
woran machen sie das fest
nein es war kein misstrauen wir haben es
ja auch gehört in einigen redebeiträgen
was ich auch richtig fahren bevor man
die überhaupt über diese einer spitze in
zukunft weiter diskutiert müssen die
strukturen noch aufgebaut werden was
eventuell mit einem generalsekretär
passiert wie kann man die befugnisse des
generalsekretärs eigentlich definieren
und das ist noch nicht geschehen von
daher wäre es auch heute zu früh gewesen
und noch mal ich freue mich mit alice
weiter vertrauensvoll hier auch als
bundesvorsitzender weiter
zusammenzuarbeiten das funktioniert in
der bundestagsfraktion wunderbar und von
daher freuen wir uns gemeinsam auf die
arbeit und wir können aktuell nicht ohne
uns
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in der scheibe